c'est que des substances qui sont en
circulation on connaît pas la
composition de chacun de ces comprimés
l'annoncé qui circulent et que parfois
ils sont forts à cause de surdoses
depuis le début de la pandémie
la crise des opioïdes s'est aggravée au
canada par exemple en colombie
britannique
cent soixante dix personnes sont mortes
par surdose au cours du mois de mai
selon le service des corner de la
province une augmentation de plus de 90
pour cent comparativement à l'an dernier
au québec le ministère de la santé et
des services sociaux n'observe pas de
hausse inhabituelle de surdoses depuis
le début de la pandémie
mais ce n'est pas l'impression des
intervenants rencontrés c'est très
difficile à quantifier parce que la
majorité de ces surdoses ont été par les
gens la communauté eux mêmes donc il va
même pas voir la colonne f1 parce que
les gens veulent pas que la police se
présente sur les lieux la fermeture des
frontières a eu un énorme impact sur
l'approvisionnement dans la rue le prix
de la cocaïne a doublé depuis le début
de la pandémie la docteure marie-eve
morais a aussi observé une baisse de la
qualité plusieurs drogues
le sus du centre ceux de l'île de
montréal a même lancé une alerte
concernant une poudre mauvais vendu
comme de l'héroïne et qui contient du
fentanyl donc quand tu sers vendus à
l'unité
on a deux options soit de la vende plus
cher ou de la coupe est davantage avec
des produits de très mauvaise qualité
pour revendre le même prix la docteure
m'aurait note aussi une augmentation de
la consommation de drogues
on n'a pas de jimpo de restaurants pas
de boutiques pas de c'est pas évident
pour les gens de remplir le vide
autrement qu'en consommant quand y avait
rien d'autre à faire un trafiquant de
drogue ne confirme d'ailleurs que les
affaires vont très bien depuis le début
du confinement
je vais définitivement plus d'argent ce
moment je pense que les gens sont là pc
savoir fait beaucoup d'argent
deux disponibles pour le grand chose à
sarralbe j'ai remarqué du client et avec
l'instabilité économique qui pointe à
l'horizon la docteure marie ève morin
s'inquiète pour ses patients
économiquement on va avoir des gros
problèmes pour les consommateurs sur ça
peut poser problème c'est peut-être là
qu'ils se tourneront vers les drogues de
moins bonne qualité ou des gestes
illégal pour se la procurer
mais moi j'ai plus peur de ce qui s'en
vient que de ce qui s'est passé
si simon couture radio canada montréal